>>Lynda: If students aren't
comfortable with who they are,
or with their behaviors
in school,
if they're not succeeding
in those kinds of ways,
then they're not going
to succeed academically.
>>Ritzy: If the child
is not behaving,
there's a need not being met.
My biggest goal is to make sure
they're getting what they need.
>>Ritzy: Do you ever
have to make a decision?
Do you know what a decision is?
>>Ashley: The approach for
Social-Emotional Learning
within the Tier System mirrors
our approach to learning
in the academic system.
>>Ritzy: Just like for
reading, and just like for math,
you need a solid
core for behavior,
for expectation,
common language.
>>Ritzy: That's right!
The difference between
conflict and bullying.
Anybody remember what
the differences are?
>>Lynda: The core instruction
for Social-Emotional
in elementary, a big part
of that is during morning
meetings every day.
That's the way that
the school day starts.
>>Ashley: You greet each other.
You get to share what's
happened in your life.
>>Teacher: Put your
thumb on your knee
when you know what
you want to share.
>>Ashley: Our core
instruction is Second Step.
And that's a program that ranges
from lessons about friendship
to conflict resolution.
And typically that happens once
a week during morning meeting,
or that could happen during
their whole learning community
meeting on Wednesday mornings.
>>Ritzy: Is bullying something
that happened one time,
or is it repeated?
>>Students: Repeated!
>>Ritzy: Is there even
power, or uneven power?
>>Students: Uneven power!
>>Ashley: Then just like
Academic Tiered instruction,
some students need
a little bit more.
Typically that Tier
2 instruction comes
from a guidance counselor,
usually within a group setting.
>>Ritzy: I group them by need,
not necessarily by grade.
We have friendship groups.
Some students, they don't know
how to initiate a friendship.
I have a grief group of children
who have lost a loved one.
I have a group for
self-regulation.
So they're getting strategies on
what to do with their emotions
when their emotions
become very strong.
>>Ritzy: Do you ever have to
make a really hard decision
because you're so angry
you don't know what to do?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Ritzy: Yeah.
I'm going to teach
you today something
that is going to help you relax.
Okay, here we go.
Gently close your eyes,
and take deep breaths.
>>So the strategy was to give
them a sense of calmness.
Go to their happy place.
Use that self-talk.
>>Go on the cloud in your
mind, and feel how soft
and comfortable it is.
>>I find that sometimes
pulling them
out is not necessarily
the answer.
Pushing-in is something
that they started doing more
so in the last three years
But I wanted to transfer some
of the skills that we learn
in my office to my classroom.
>>If you can get them to do
that enough times, they're going
to feel that success
in the classroom.
They're going to feel
successful learning.
>>Ashley: Some students
need more intensive support,
and so then they would usually
meet with the guidance counselor
in Tier 3, more one-on-one.
>>Ritzy: For instance, a child
is bullying other children.
That child wouldn't
be in Tier 2.
Most children that are doing
bullying have very specific
needs, so you would have that
child meet with me individually.
I usually work really
closely with School Psych.
The trajectory or the
need may be an evaluation.
Then they're more likely to
get involved with that child.
>>Will you let me
know right away,
so that way I can pull him
in, because he did really well
when we put him on that
behavior plan last year.
>>Ashley: Our student
success team meets every
four-and-a-half weeks.
And we talk through what types
of support the kids need.
>>Lynda: There are many
people around the table.
The classroom teachers
are there.
The learning community leader,
school counseling is there.
Somebody from school
psychology is there,
an administrator is there.
>>Ritzy: Decisions are made
of all of us as a group.
So it's not like the
teacher says, "Okay,
I want them in Tier 2.
Put them in there."
>>Teacher: It happens
every time.
Helping him see the pattern of
the people that he sits with
and the pattern of arguments
and frustration that he has.
Because I think it's
frustrating for him, too.
I honestly don't think that he
really recognizes that pattern.
>>Ritzy: Is he-- and I know that
at one point Peter was refusing
to take his medication.
>>Based on his behavior he is.
>>I would say, he
seems like, yes.
>>I would say he seems like yes.
>>Because it's very noticeable.
>>No, I just put in that Ritzy's
is going to continue to work
with Peter on these issues,
but also working with Mom.
>>Ritzy: Quantifying their
progress is what sets
up a challenge.
Because how do you
quantify self-esteem?
I usually do some form
of evaluation that I know
that the child is understanding
the message, or the skill
that they're trying to practice.
Usually there is observations,
pre and post-teacher
input gives me data.
Parent input.
I use rating skills that
give me information,
but not necessarily
scientifically
coded information.
We go back and every nine weeks
at the SSTs I ask do they
still need my services?
So if this child has made
enough progress, we remove them.
I may do a check-in, I may do
a follow-up, but it all depends
at the need of every
specific student.
I want to make sure that
every child that walks
through those doors is treated
in a way that's with respect
and love and kindness.
And I want to treat every child
like I would want my
own to be treated.